so let's see how we could approach 4 and
1 4 minus
2 and 2 4. pause this video and have a
go at that before we work on this
together
all right
so the first thing that you might try to
do is rewrite this as 4
and 1 4
minus
2
and 2 4. and the reason why it's useful
to write it this way is we could say
look each of these mixed numbers have a
whole number part and then they have a
fractional part and so i could try to
subtract the fractional part from the
fractional part and then the whole
number apart from the whole number part
and that will often work but when we go
to just the fractional parts and we say
hey how do i subtract two-fourths from
one-fourth two-fourths is larger than
one-fourth you immediately might find
yourself in something of a conundrum so
what do you do
well what comes to the rescue is a
notion called regrouping and that's that
we're not just subtracting two-fourths
from one-fourth we're subtracting two
and two-fourths from four and one-fourth
so what we could do is we could take
some of the value that's in this four
and regroup it into the fraction what do
i mean by that
well instead of four if i view four as
three
and four fourths
four fourths
and so four-fourths plus one-fourth is
five-fourths five-fourths
so i can rewrite this as three and
five-fourths minus two and two-fourths
once again why is that useful because
five-fourths is greater than two-fourths
what is five-fourths minus two-fourths
well that's going to be three-fourths
and then what is three minus two well
that's going to be one and we get one
and three fourths another way we could
have thought about it is this is the
same thing as
four
minus 2
plus 1 4
plus 1 4
minus 2 4 minus 2 4. and we have trouble
with the 1 4 minus 2 4. that's what we
saw right over here so we do is we take
some of that value from the 4.
instead of 4 we could rewrite that as 3
plus
4
4 that's the same thing as 4 and of
course you have minus 2
plus 1 4 minus 2 4
and then if you add the 4 4 to the 1 4
that's going to give us 5 4. so you're
going to have 3
minus 2
that's that part in that part and then
you're going to have if you have the
four-fourths and the one-fourth so plus
five-fourths
minus two-fourths and that's exactly
what we have here three and five-fourths
three and five-fourths
minus two minus two and minus two
fourths and so three minus two is one
five-fourths minus two-fourths is
three-fourths